one of the many aspects of the tragedy
of Turing's death is that he wasn't able
to tell us more about how he was
thinking about his last communications
so I have to trout on very delicate and
uncertain territory because I don't want
to put words in his mouth or assume so
Alan Turing invented computers and he
was the first after he broke Nazi secret
code using computers and no one had done
anything like that before
and he was in a remarkable strange
historical position because his
invention of competing made him one of
the encuesta boleros of World War two
however he emerged from it as somebody
who was living illegally in his own
society because he was gay at a time
when it was illegal to be gay in Britain
at a certain point without going into
all the details he was put under house
arrest and subjected to a torturous
medical regime that was supposed to
change his sexual orientation so that he
would become straight and it involved of
forcing him to accept massive doses of
female hormones and he generated breasts
and other female characteristics and
became very depressed and he killed
himself in front of his computer using a
very strange ritual sort of like I mean
who can know what he was thinking but he
laced an apple with Simon ADA the reason
to tell this horrible story is just to
point out that the invention of the
artificial intelligence idea the
invention of the idea that the computer
is doing something on its own and that
it's not just being programmed came out
of Turing's mind during this last very
last period of his life in the weeks
before his death and he wrote a couple
of notes about it in this argument
that's known as the Turing test he
proposed that a computer that could
[Music]
answer questions and be
indistinguishable to a judge from
real person perhaps should be treated as
a real person because who are we to deny
it moral Rives and I think if you look
at the argument in the abstract it looks
like an argument for computationalism
that computers and people are
fundamentally the saying that the big
that we are building a big entity in the
internet and all that but if you look at
in the context of Turing's life a
completely different picture appears
which is you realize here's this person
who's being murdered for who he is
after not going to be one of the heroes
of liberating people who are being
murdered for who they were when you
realize the absolute and thunderous
irony of his situation and then you
think about his having created the
thought experiment where he's saying
should this weird creature have rights I
think it puts it in a very different
life and I think the right way to
understand Turing is to understand that
this whole thought began in the mind of
somebody who was in a deeply deeply
uncomfortable possible situation very
close to suicide and that it amounted to
a flag from life but also a defense of
life it could have been a lot of things
it could have been a reductio ad
absurdum if you're telling me that I
don't deserve to be a human as I am well
then make this machine human it could
have been that sort of thing and I think
it's very possibly what it was it could
also have been my god what would it take
for you people to give anybody respect
what's the secret you know a sort of a
desperate cry of like what is the secret
code to get some respect as a person
around here I don't really know but the
point I want to make is that the the
wrong interpretation is surely the one
that has taken hold which is oh yeah
let's treat the computers as people you
know so turning invented this whole
thing he made of computers and the whole
came out of his head pretty much well no
I'm it also did part of it of course but
the basic track that we're all still
grooving in was laid down by the sky
it was murdered by his own government
for being gay and we should
forget that that's our origin that's the
real you know I think when you really
delve into the truth to the human
stories you start to discover things
that are quite different from the
abstractions and the generalities